امريكي من الحزب الجمهوري معروف بدعمه
لاوكرانيا ودفاعه بقوه عن زياده المساعدات
العسكريه لاوكرانيا في مواجهه روسيا
والجمعه زار ابراهام اوكرانيا
للمره الثالثه من وقت بدايه الحرب لكن هذه
المره الجدل حول هذه الزياره كان اكثر من
اي مره والسبب مقطع نشرته الرئاسه
الاوكرانيه بعد اللقاء اللي جمع الرئيس
الاوكراني بالسنتر الامريكي
مثل ما شفتوا في المقطع السيناتور
الامريكي بيقول انه الروس جالسين بيموتوا
وهذه افضل اموال انفقتها امريكا وطبعا
التصريح قلب الدنيا عليه في روسيا واشتعلت
الانتقادات والادانات له نائب رئيس مجلس
الامن الروسي
قال انه السنه العجوز احمق وما كان لازم
انه يقول اللي قالوا اما المتحدثه باسم
الخارجيه الروسيه ماريا زخروا فقالت انه
نسي يقراهم يقول انه امريكا بتضحي بحياه
الامريكيين علشان تقتل الروس اما المتحدث
باسم الكريم
فقال انه ما في عار اكبر على امريكا من
وجود سنه مثل هؤلاء امام الهجوم هذا جرام
ورد او ورد في ايميل عبر رويترز وقال انه
كالعاده ماكينه البروفيجندا الروسيه
اشتغلت وقال انه كلامه
اوكرانيا تبنت شعار امريكي هو عش حرا او
مت وانه هذا كان الاستثمار امريكي جيد وفي
مجمل رد رد تحديدا على رئيس مجلس الامن
الروسي اللي وصفوه بالاحمق وقال له انه لو
تبغى توقف موت الروس فوقف الحرب لكن
الحقيقه انه لا انت ولا بوتين سائلين عن
الجنود الروس بعد كل هذا شفنا مفاجاه
فالرئاسه الاوكرانيه فجاه نزلت فيديو تاني
للقاء كاملا والفيديو بيظهر انه الجملتين
اللي قالهم السنه ما كانوا ورا بعض ولا
كانوا اصلا في نفس السياق
[موسيقى]
تاعي
هامل
لكن الهجوم الروسي ما وقف لا بل تصعد
والداخليه الروسيه اعلنت وضع السيناتور
الامريكي على قوائم المطلوبين وقالت انها
فتحت تحقيق جنائي حول التصريحات لكن ما
وضحت ايش الجريمه اللي بيشتبه انه ارتكبها
طيب ينضم الينا من كيف الصحفي محمد البابا
اهلا فيك معنا محمد طبعا يعني
الموضوع كان شويه غريب لانه اول شيء نزل
الفيديو بعدين رجع نزل فيديو تاني طيب
الفيديو الاول هل نقدر نقول انه في انطباع
انه كان متعمد انه يتمنتج بهذه الطريقه او
لا يعني التاخد بحسن نيه يعني
بالحقيقه يعني اول شيء الرئيس الاوكراني
وفريق عمله وخاصه فريق الاعلام اللي جنبه
هم من خلفيه اعلاميه ويعلمون كيفيه
استخدام جميع الفرص لاعطاء كدعايه ودعم
لاوكرانيا وعاده عندما يكون هناك ضيوف عند
الرئيس الاوكراني
بيصدر متل بيانات او مقتطفات من اللقاءات
مع المسؤولين يعني الزوار
لكسر ماريانكا او للاداره الرئاسيه او حتى
للرئيس الاوكراني ولكن يعني تحديدا كيفيه
يعني المونتاج وما حصل في هذا التسجيل هو
يثير الريبه خاصه يعني تم اختيار الكلمات
الاقصى عندما تحدث انه يجب يعني رشا
والداي او الروس سيموتون هو الترجمه
الصحيحه
يعني الروس سيموتون جاء ضمن سياق خاصه
يعني قبل الزياره بيوم كان هناك استهداف
مستشفى في اوكرانيا وانا استوضحت يعني مع
يعني مع مقربين من الاداره الرئاسيه حول
طبيعه كيفيه انشاء او كيفيه الحديد يعني
كان في استياء ليله الزياره انه كان في
استهداف لاحدى المستشفيات في مدينه
ضحايا وبخلال الجلسه اللي بعيده كان التي
لم تكن مسجله في البدايه بعض الاحاديث
الجانبيه كان يتحدثون عن هذا الوضع وكان
الطرفان الرئيس الاوكراني وحتى يعني
السيناتور اللينسي يتحدثون بقساوه لان
يعني كان هناك جريمه كبيره هزه ولكن ما
خرج في هذا التسجيل يعني يثير الريبه خاصه
كيفيه يعني المونتاج الذي
ظهر في البدايه ان يدعو ان
يدعو او يقول ان يعني الولايات المتحده
تقدم الدعم ليموت الرسوم هنا يعني
البرتغندا الروسيه كما تصف في اوكرانيا
استغلت هذه النقطه لاشعال الراي العام
الروسي ان
روسيا هي مع الامريكان الذين يمولون
اوكرانيا بالمال والسلاح لقتل
تحدث عن هذا الموضوع وقال انه بالفعل
اشتغلت
الروسيه ولكن لما تتحدث محمد عن
انه تقول انه الفيديو طريقه تمنتجته تثير
الريبه يعني نقدر نقول انه فعلا الرئيس
الاوكراني يعني كان حابب انه ايه حابب انه
يسبب ازمه بين امريكا وروسيا حابب يزيدها
شعر
يعني عاده
الاوكرانيين يريدون حشد الدعم من الجميع
ضد روسيا الجانب الاوكراني يحاول استغلال
اي فرصه ليكون هناك دعم لاوكرانيا لمواجهه
روسيا حتى في الرياضه التي هي بعيده عن
السياسه كان الرئيس الاوكراني يعني وقت
كاس العالم كان الرئيس الاوكراني يريد
القاء كلمه يعني بشد الانصار والحصول على
دعم وتاييد لاوكرانيا بوجه روسيا ويعني
هذا حقه يعني حق مشروع لاي شخص للحصول على
الدعم ولكن ونفس الشيء كمان ايضا طلب انه
يتحدث او يلقي الكلمه
صحيح صحيح اي فرصه يعني يحاول الرئيس
الاوكراني وفي طريقه الحصول واستغلال جميع
الفرص
لابراست صوره اوكرانيا لشتى التعاطف ولو
بالقوه يمكنك للحشد التعاطف والدعم ليش
اعادوا نشر الفيديو كاملا غير ممنتج هل
يكون هذا بسبب مثلا طلب من السنه
ايش يكون الموضوع وهل الفيديو الجديد
الكامل حصد نفس الاهتمام اللي حصده
الفيديو الاول في اوكرانيا نعم حاصت في
اوكرانيا والدول الغربيات يعني بالبدايه
الدوائر الامريكيه تعمل ضمن الاسطل
والقوانين لذلك يعني كان المفروض على
الجانب الاوكراني توضيح يعني خلفيه
تصريحات لانه ربما ستكون هناك مساءلات من
الخارجيه الامريكيه او داخل يعني السلطات
الامريكيه المتحده الامريكيه لهذا لهذا
السيناتور حول طبيعه التصحيح وكيف جاء
لذلك الجانب الاوكراني اخلاقي عليه ان
ينشر كامل التشغيل لايضاح للراي العام
كيفيه او او في او سياق الحديث الذي حصل
الجانب الاوكراني خرج منتصرا يعني ضمن
الحمله او البروفاجندر الروسيه التي تجيش
الراي العام الروسي هناك حمله اخرى
تثبت دائما ان الروس يراهنون على
المعلومات وعلى المواضيع الخاطئه وهذا ما
يستغل هذه الطريقه يلي عم تستغلها ايضا
الاوكرانيين لابراز ان روسيا تريد اشعال
وتحميل الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
مسؤوليه الحرب التي بداتها
انطباعات خلق انطباعات من الطرفين طيب
الان لما الجانب الروسي يطلع ويقول انه
وضع السنه الامريكي على قوائم المطلوبين
قد ايش هذه الخطوه فعلا يعني كبيره او
مهمه او
يعني اولا السيناتور لن يقوم بزياره
امريكا لزياره روسيا لانه يعني يرفض
النظام الروسي ويرفض تص الاداره البوتينيه
كما توصف في اوكرانيا لذلك هي لا تؤثر هذه
عقوبات مثل العقوبات التي فرضت من
اوكرانيا على قوت ايضا يعني هي هي عقوبات
شكليه وليس لها او يعني
يكون لها تاثير حتى يعني عندما يكون الغرب
باي عقوبات او منع سفر مثلا لمسؤولين روس
هذا يؤثر على رؤوس ولكن الروس لا يستطيعون
فرض اي تاثيرات اللي منع سفر مثلا او له
احتجاز او اعتقال اي شخص خارج عن سيطره
روسيا او خارج يعني نفوز روسيا يعني اكيد
يعني هم حيروح يقضي عندهم اي اجازه قريبا
مثلا
طيب نحن بنشكرك على هذه التوضيحات كان
معنا من كيف الصحفي محمد البابا شكرا لك
محمد
[موسيقى]